[Musique]
je pense qu'il apporte un enracinement
sur le territoire où les enfants vivent
et en même temps une ouverture au monde
pour résumer ça en 22.1 harris un ara
cinéma dans la culture dans la
l'histoire dans tout ce qu'ils aient
connaissance géographique si puisqu'on a
de la toponymie pour expliquer le monde
et une ouverture puisque l'enfant va
grandir en deux langues et d'ella de la
maternelle il
il apprendra que finalement il n'y a pas
une seule vérité est que les choses
peuvent être vues de 2.2 i i là il va
découvrir et accepter aussi la
relativité des choses et peut-être nous
l'espérons du moins s est un peu ce qui
a transparu dans les cursus des enfants
et des adolescents et des adultes
maintenant c'est que ils ont une
curiosité pour la culture de l'autre et
un respect nous vivons au 21e siècle il
est impératif que tout enfant tout
adolescent phase d'apprentissage de
langue véhiculaire les langues
internationales
on a souvent dit que le français était
attendue des idées que l'anglais est la
langue du commerce
il est évident que l'anglais est quelque
chose de vital moyennant cette seule
réserve
je partage tout à fait l'avis de madame
je pense que l'apprentissage d'une
langue régionale qui vous rattache à
votre culture à vos racines est très
bénéfique
elle ouvre l'esprit et vous re si tu es
vous en racines mais l'addition qu'on
néglige pas les deux autres qui
aujourd'hui sont des outils absolument
indispensable il faut promouvoir la
langue qu'il s'agisse de langue
française et de langue régionale
comment nous comme le fait un mètre
hôtel quand vous allez au restaurant il
faut faire saliver les gens la langue
c'est un plaisir alors pourquoi la
langue française en priorité parce que
elle a des problèmes et ses plans to
them tous mes amis qui font passer des
écrits et des zorro dans les concours
les plus prestigieux
normale sup ou polytechnique et bien
d'autres s'apitoie dans la mesure où il
assiste à une baisse très nette de la
qualité du français écrit et parlé
[Musique]
depuis 2010 neuf il ya eu le ministre
blanquet ramière en place la réforme des
lycées par exemple
cette préférence vue du lycée a entraîné
quelque chose d'assez grave pour les
landes un général et là il faut se
rendre compte que tout ce qui n'est pas
l'un d'eux un élan gh2 c'est-à-dire tout
ce qui était langue optionnelle on peut
citer par exemple
l'italien le portugais l'espagnol dans
certaines zones l'allemande dans
d'autres mais aussi des larmes plus
exotiques chinois ou ou le japonais qui
étaient des possibilités qui existait
dans certains lycées et qu'ils étaient
donc des landes en option troisième l'an
de celles actuellement c'est l'un d'eux
tous debout avec la réforme du lycée et
du bas perdre et intérêts si je puis
dire pour les élèves au niveau des
points qui portait alors évidemment il y
aura des passionnés de langues qui vont
continuer à faire à prendre cette option
même si elle ne leur rapporte rien si ce
n'est une note dans la moyenne d'heures
de l'heure de leur bac mais en tout cas
c'est un geste qui pour nous est
peut-être catastrophique parce que
autant les langues étrangères sont
toujours enseigné est vécue dans leur
pays d'origine
autant les langues régionales ne peuvent
être conseillés que sur le territoire
français
thor d'abord on a un pouvoir exécutif
qui ne sait pas gérer le temps long on
ne gouverne pas la langue et les langues
de façon brutale par à coups
et certainement pas par décret ça c'est
catastrophique parce que ça c'est un
mauvais paratonnerre qui dévie l'opinion
publique des vrais problèmes
l'éducation nationale souffre d'un
problème global
le sous paiement des enseignants ne joue
ap le monde est un des pays de l'europe
développée dans lequel les personnels
soignants comme le personnel enseignant
ont les plus bas salaires en europe
évidemment ça applique une dégradation
ne serait ce que dans la sélection au
concours aux examens et il ya de plus en
plus d'enseignants je viens moi-même
d'éduquer sur la seule mais il ya de
plus en plus d'enseignants et qui ont
une maîtrise défaillance de la langue
française comme d'ailleurs il ya eu une
maîtrise défaillant de tous les
fondamentaux donc de plus en plus
certains enseignants sont sous forme et
peuvent être sous qualifiée parce qu'ils
sont sous payés et que ça n'attire pas
quand vous êtes fort en maths je ne vais
pas envie de prendre vous préférez avoir
une carrière qui vous apportera plus
d'argent et donc là il ya quelque chose
de catastrophique donc là il ya un
énorme problème alors je n'ai pas du
tout une vision d'une évolution
décadente depuis lomé sur terre depuis
des siècles il ya toujours des grincheux
qui tout fout l'camp cas plus de saison
qu'à plus de jeunesse qui a plus de
valeur et que tout se dégrade
non l'histoire c'est un mouvement
pendulaire
il ya des moments où le balancier va
dans le mauvais sens les moments où on y
va dans le bon sens mais mécaniquement
et logiquement tôt ou tard il ira dans
l'autre sens